heyo welcome to Rotten Tomatoes HQ I'm
Jacqueline this.g goon the Star Wars
last Jedi trailer was just released so
we're gonna take a second now and take a
second look at it and break it down
ready ready I'm just loving the way it
opened up it felt like a mob movie 0:01
where you've got like dinero overlooking
the casino in Vegas so we get another
look at the different start up
stormtroopers don't you feel like they
just like change up stormtroopers with
every one of these movies there's like a
different version what but I don't mind
that
yeah because to me it's like it's like
just it's like ninjas like sometimes the
ninjas have on these color please white
helmets and they got black one I just I
like it I this right here this
particular scene where he picks up the
say he we don't know but I think that's
his ghetto lightsaber that he is did you
say get it is so rigged it is so rigged
that is not a normal lightsaber you've
seen him hold it okay I'm just gonna say
I'm sorry it is it is like a rigged
lightsaber I'll say rigged oh so that
was Snoke Snoke doing the voice over
which i think is very interesting that
he's doing the voice over in this one
see I how do you feel about that they
had um Lupita nyong'o's character do the
voice over in the force awakens and then
she ended up being this whole source of
wisdom there was that whole story and I
loved it who doesn't love Lupita yeah
but I feel like with this one like that
was Maz Kanata and so I feel like with
this one she's gonna be or this Snoke is
gonna be like the explainer for the dark
side of the force which I'm actually
really excited to see the whole trailers
dark yeah so they from the very from the
opening of the mobster look or the game
basically the gangster look I from start
to finish
I got an overall dark feeling from this
movie which is great cuz I don't need my
Star Wars to be like you know sunshine
and funny I like conflict I like dark
why like Darth Maul so I mean I think
it's gonna get dark because again if
they go in the model of like modeling
the first Star Wars trilogy force
awakens sets the world like a new hope
did Empire Strikes Back obviously gets
darker so
this film I'm expecting it darkens
alright so ray with Luke's lightsaber
back on island just the branding on the
lucasfilm's
I mean it's everywhere but this is
iconic like his face right here is real
different from the face we got at the
end of the force awakens like he looks
like confused and angry and I just feel
like we're probably gonna get like gruff
old man like Luke but that's fine
because he's a slash right now right now
he's he's half obi-wan he's giving you
may be some Yoda like he's he's like
I've gone to my far away Mountain I
don't want to be bothered if you
remember Yoda was in this like most
likely out please yeah
another her might master but unlike Yoda
who I feel was like a semi reluctant I
feel like Luke is gonna be like way more
reluctant in this based off of what we
see you later so sorry I member you
wanted everybody yeah no I'm not gonna
go back to so these books like this is
something that the Internet has been
obsessing over since the teaser trailer
so there's the idea that like after kylo
went crazy Luke started like going
through the Stars and he sort of got
lost for those who don't know she that
was kylo Ren kylo Ren thank you so after
kylo Ren murdered all of the other Jedi
people that Luke was training obviously
these are the events before the force
awakens the assumption is that Luke goes
and looks for something and he's looking
for more mythology about the fourth and
I think these books or supposedly maybe
like you know right so basically it's
the but it's the general yeah and my
Bible Koran or whatever makes you feel
good but that's where the wisdom is
story yeah cuz from the first one it's
like he's got this idea of like I went
back and looked at something and I
learned that things are not what you
think so
[Music]
good job Meg now we're looking at her
power okay yeah
so go back to Luke's face right here
he's shot he's he's seen power unlike
anything he's seen before that's good
that's terrifying for him because I
would bet the last time he saw that kind
of power was with kylo and at first
probably with him he was like oh my god
this is so great and now he knows no
this is about to mess some stuff up
look at that face man see I I know I get
your point but I'm thinking that it if
he saw it once before and it betrayed
him and it was the dark side maybe she
has the ability to be the equal opposite
the yin-yang of good and so so that
gives it to another like fan theory that
people have we'll get to that a little
bit later because that's a big fan
theory too like that maybe they're both
sides of the same coin that would make
more sense for all the people who are
just coming to this late yes so here's
Kyla I'm guessing this is probably gonna
be immediately after the events of the
force awakens because he still has like
what looks to me to be like a healing
patch yeah on his face I was looking at
the scar and I was wondering where how
they were going to explain it or was
from the from the initial fight in what
that's got to be talked about yeah I
think that's when the initial fight this
is Leia obviously on her starship
general Leia Organa and it looks almost
like he's concentrating shooting but how
sad did that make you just to see the
carry-on fit they had her so much in the
thing that it just I know it routes you
in mythology and all of the movies of
Star Wars I mean she's Princess Leia but
it just it was it hurt yes not you know
she's not there ya know it hurts like
anytime you have post Thomas rolls like
this where someone died and then the
work comes out afterwards it's always
really weird it was like like a lien
Queen of the Damned where you're just
like oh I see oh man I you missed them
immediate like I miss her immediately
and I watch it and I see exactly you
know like oh my gosh like she was gonna
be in been a bigger partner I would like
to get dark right like with chief ledger
like the fact that he was brilliant in
it and then you're even more sad so
that's so this Christmas which
if it keeps on giving let's talk about
it Shoei wait a minute can we just talk
about the porks and how like we watched
it like the group of us that were
huddled around the TV all just loved
this moment like I love you so much
you know what the Ewoks get a bad rap
and I feel like the porks might like at
first
when the toys were announced when they
didn't have any like thing to ground
them with they got a bad rap but I have
a feeling this this is gonna be the
cutest thing who doesn't like c'mere
like owl penguins they've got big eyes
[Music]
so he said we're gonna be the spark that
lights the flame to burn the first order
down I mean I just love Poe as the
revolutionary I'm you know I'm I he
seems a bit superfluous for me like I
could the internet is so mad at you give
me my Jedi's gift look give me my Jedi's
give me look I don't mind he walks he my
he walks I like to eat well we need
pilots han was a pilot the pilots are a
part of mythology as much as the world
like this feels a lot light to me you
know what the internet there's a
thousand tumblr pages
I'll just centered around the bromance
between Finn and Poe it's like called
storm pilot and those women are gonna
find you in the comments I'm just gonna
let you know oh and this right here you
can see Finn's face mm in the reflection
of asthma's helmet how great is this and
I think this is going to sort of end the
thing that a lot of people complain
about is you have this woman captain
phasma who is just like this big you
know did they underutilized her in the
first movie and this trailer sets up
what we've been hoping for
we get to see Brienne of Tarth go
full-out Game of Thrones against the
Hound in a Star Wars movie
I mean don't don't be mad at me for
dropping this but I saw a Grendel and
Christiana dance girl I talked to her
and I said write you a ticket I know but
values particularly and she says girl
I've been doing so much sword work she
says I'm doing more sword work okay than
I did for Game of Thrones so I have a
feeling the because I need to have it
yeah there's gonna be an epic fight I'm
excited and then we got bb-8 back to
luke right what that is some kind of ice
crystal fox and i love it i don't care
what it is I just need to have one is it
that yeah that one was random to me but
I have a feeling it's gonna be
significant and then Leia again just
looking at Amazing Race swimming yeah
just like the sets if you're if you
don't know Star Wars or if you're not if
you're new to all of this you're looking
at sets and just I mean look how much is
right here in this one frozen frame just
just black white it just yeah
when we get to the unit all right
obviously another battle on that red
planet that was talking first and then
let's go back cuz I really wanna talk
about we get our first best shot of
Snoke in real life and honestly the
Internet has already matched this up
with Gollum yes from hey you guys from
The Goonies
got Chomp Chomp no small flaw yes
they've already mashed that up and I'm
sure Gollum will be next but this is
Annie circuses character and this is an
entire CGI character
look how real that looks you know again
when you're dealing with George Lucas
you do know with Lucas art and light
magic they they bring it to life yeah
with the most the eyes look real yeah
but it looked like it could be a person
in makeup but it's not yeah I want to
listen to his voice over here because I
feel like it's got some clues
[Music]
so it looks like he's holding rate yeah
your destiny and then and then they fade
it to black but it looks like he's going
to try and bring something out of her
that shot of him raising his hand to her
you you have an idea that it has to
happen from the last moment where
they're fighting and that mutual like he
mutiny respected her power or more he
was shocked at how much because remember
at the end of words awakened yeah I
think it was a grudging respect like oh
this she's bringing it she's coming with
it so this is what made everyone gasp
the part that everyone is crazy about
Star Wars blast Jedi and crane one thing
there's the whole idea of the light in
the dark mm-hmm dark side of the force
yeah so emo Darth Vader kylo Ren emo
Darth Vader dark side of the force
if Rey ends up being that more
counterpoint to the light like the idea
of them coming together is both like
terrifying but also like terrified it
could be really bad like I just feel
like both of them like anytime anybody's
dealing with someone that's on the dark
side of folks I mean he committed
patricide like he killed his father like
he's never coming back from that he's
evil so the idea is in teaming up at all
I think you might be misunderstood I
don't know like I don't I'm not gonna go
full-on evil yet I mean he extends the
hand my evil people are just like you
know don't extend the hand that's an
olive branch like let's go work together
and again if there if there are two
sides of the same coin to make the
complete coin you need both sides so the
light side of the force and the dark
side of the force
joint that makes for good watching yeah
I mean it's not that much different when
Luke I am your father
and Darth Vader reaches out and you know
I mean no you're right there is a whole
side of the mythology to where they talk
about how maybe the Jedi had it wrong by
they were just going to the light side
but anyway that's our thoughts please
let us know in the comments what your
thoughts are on the trailer are you
excited for Star Wars last Jedi I would
figure that you were because if you
leave comments we're gonna figure that
you're excited but honestly they did
this during Monday Night Football
so they'd have to imagine that not only
multiple multiple eyeballs are gonna be
watching this not only fans but I think
this movie is going to be yeah I really
alright thanks guys
we'll see you next time
[Music]